bonjour à tous très 2 d'autres
aujourd'hui pour vous parler du futur
galaxy s 9 et s9 plus on a plein d'infos
des choses très concrètes et ça
justement on va en parler
[Musique]
galaxy s 9 s9 plus samsung
c'est des choses qui vont arriver très
rapidement il ya des rumeurs tous les
côtés il ya plein d'infos ya pléthore
d'informations et là on sait plus par
quel boulet prendra alors justement on a
une date de sortie
on sait quand est ce qu'il va être
annoncée on sait également pour voir le
pré commander et on sait à quel moment
on va pouvoir le recevoir
ça c'est bien on a un peu la fiche
technique on sait à quoi va ressembler
on connaît un peu les grandes lignes des
nouveautés on a plein d'infos non qu'on
a vraiment un portrait robot de ce à
quoi va ressembler vont ressembler les
futurs samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus
alors on va tout de suite commencer par
les dates de sorties cd smartphones qui
vont être annoncé au mwc très très très
bientôt à barcelone alors qu'est ce que
c'est que le mwc si vous ne connaissez
pas c'est le mot bail ou en congrès ce
c'est un petit peu la grande messe de la
téléphonie mobile
tous les grands de la téléphonie mobile
seront là avec les nouveautés et ya
effectivement des choses qui vont être
annoncées à ce moment-là dont justement
samsung avec ses futurs s9 et s9 plus
alors justement cette année lui awc aura
lieu du 26 février au 1er mars
et c'est justement le 26 février que
samsung devrait faire l'annoncé
officielle de ces galaxies s9 et s9 plus
vous deviez pouvoir les précommandes et
à partir du 1er mars et les recevoir à
partir du 16 mars
on voit effectivement que le calendrier
est assez rapprochés ils vont arriver
très rapidement sans marcher
effectivement pour couper un petit peu
l'herbe sous le pied apple et son iphone
10 parce qu'il faut que samsung organise
un petit peu de terrain par rapport à
apple donc il très important que ce
smartphone sorte assez rapidement en
2018 et des infos qui nous viennent
d'athènes alors un appel c'est le
régulateur de la télécommunication au
brésil et ils ont publié des
informations concernant les batteries
des futures galaxy s 9 et 9 plus on
s'attendait pour le galaxy s 9 avoir une
batterie de 3200 milliards perreur a
priori ça ne sera pas le cas on aura une
batterie de 3000 millions période
exactement comme son prédécesseur le la
suite idem pour le s9 plus une batterie
de trois mille cinq cents millions
erreur pas de grand changement de ce
côté là cette année par contre ces
galaxies asma phase 9 + devrait avoir un
dos métal 12 qui serait un alliage
d'aluminium et de magnésium
c'est à dire très résistant et surtout
très léger pour gagner encore en poids
dans vos poches ou dans vos sacs à main
côté écran le s9 devrait avoir
exactement la même dimension que la
suite un écran 5 10 pouces écran
infiniti super amoled avec un ratio de
18 points 5/9 alors bien évidemment un
écran toujours incurvé toujours bord à
bord la différence doit se faire avec le
galaxy s 9 plus lui par contre devrait
occuper 90% de la surface avant alors
son prédécesseur le et suit plus occupés
84%
la grosse nouveauté le gros changement
se fait au niveau de l'appareil photo
appareil photo arrière on devrait avoir
un capteur photo arrière 12 méga dual
pixels un appareil photo
super speed qui ira toujours plus vite
pour la prise de vos photos une
stabilisation optique de l'image mais
surtout la grande nouveauté
l'innovation majeure de ce produit c'est
la double ouverture
vous devriez avoir une ouverture en 1.5
par faible luminosité et une ouverture
de 2.4 lorsque la luminosité sera
complètement optimale ça c'est vraiment
beau parce qu'on ne retrouve sur aucun
smartphone sur le marché ça permet
encore d'aller plus loin sur la qualité
de vos photos d'avoir une vraie
réduction de bruit et des images
d'encore une meilleure qualité
en plus de ça le super slow motion va
faire son apparition chez samsung s'en
retrouve déjà sur le sony exode premium
on va le retrouver sur ses futurs
samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus l'année
prochaine
alors ça s'adresse très clairement aux
créateurs contenu si vous amuser à faire
de la vidéo en tant qu'amateur pour
partager des souvenirs je vois pas
particulièrement le besoin vous allez
avoir d'affaires du super slow motion
si ce n'est quelques souvenirs heureux à
gauche par contre très clairement la
stratégie de samsung c'est de séduire
les créateurs contenu c'est pas nouveau
jacques dernière et s'était passé à la
vitesse supérieure là cette année avec
les s 9 vs 9 plus ils vont aller encore
plus loin il y a plus en plus de
créateur contenus qui font des photos
des photos de qualité que ce soit sur
instagram que ce soit sur snapshot mais
on va pouvoir encore plus loin sur la
vidéo est là avec le super slow motion
on pourra faire des effets de dingue
alors c'est vrai que sony et son higgs
aide premium même si c'est un très bon
produit un peu plus confidentiels sony
scapa parmi les leaders du marché
c'est vrai que ce produit on retrouve
pas partout par contre très clairement
les produits de samsung font toujours un
carton
samsung avec apple sur toujours un petit
peu au coude à coude pour savoir qui
sera le premier qui sera le deuxième
pour ça des prospectives mans le moment
de l'année où on regarde si c'est plutôt
du deuxième semestre ou du premier
semestre
apple a toujours tendance un petit peu
rattrapé son retard en fin d'année alors
que samsung lors tout s'est produit en
début d'année donc voilà sont toujours
un petit peu au coude à coude dans un
mouchoir poche mais elle a très
clairement avec le super slow motion
samsung va aller encore plus loin côté
celle que de retrouver une caméra de 8
mégapixels avec un autofocus
le galaxy s 9 + devrait avoir un art y
ait un double capteur photo alors que
galaxy s 9
on n'aura qu'un seul il faut toujours
garder le scanner d'iris le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui par contre
sera passé en dessous en dessous du
capteur photo comme on peut retrouver
sur les à 8 et a8 plus
[Musique]
bon alors si ils font exactement la même
chose que sur les à 8 à huit de plus
c'est pas encore génial parce que on a
toujours tendance à laisser un petit
bout du doigt traîner sur le capteur
photo les cds bulma c'est pas optimal il
faudrait qu'il soit passé un peu plus
bas et là effectivement ça se réduit
alors j'imagine que pour des coûts de
fabrication
il aimait d'avoir une seule en coche au
niveau de la coque plutôt que d'en avoir
deux ça coûte et probablement un peu
plus cher à faire mais toujours est il
que cet emplacement s'est pas encore
complètement ça bien évidemment il y
aura une recharge par induction une
certification ip68 résistante à l'eau et
à la poussière
des haut-parleurs stéréo à kg des
écouteurs à kg 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage qu'on va pouvoir étendre bien
évidemment avec une carte microsd
on devrait trouver un processeur exynos
9810 en europe est un qualcomm
snapdragon 845 aux états unis et en
chine
samsung a déposé une marque il ya très
peu de temps marc en anglais the camera
raw imagined alors excusez mon accent il
est complètement affective
j'en ai conscience bien évidemment on va
le faire à la française la caméra ou
l'appareil photo ré-imaginer réinventer
on peut entendre comme ça c'est
effectivement dans ce sens que vale
samsung ils vont vraiment communiquer
sur un meilleur appareil photo
la double ouverture c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire sur ce type d'appareil
c'est génial le fait d'avoir du super
slow motion même si sony a sorti l'année
dernière on voit que pour un produit
chez samsung
c'est vraiment nouveau donc ils vont
encore plus loin au niveau de la photo
encore plus loin au niveau de la vidéo
et ça gros pouce c'est génial on va
également retrouver toujours la présence
du port jack ça pour moi c'est pareil en
gros pouce très grand fan je vous disais
capteurs des risques va être conservé
il devrait être retravaillé amélioré
pour ouvrir encore plus vite pour
déverrouiller toujours plus vite et pour
concurrencer surtout failli saïdi c'est
vrai qu'apple a qui sont faits saïdiya
quand même marqué énormément de points
et il faut toujours des solutions
innovantes toujours plus de sécurité
pour réussir à déverrouiller en un clin
d'oeil pour résumer ce convoi ex-épouse
promo de cs 9 vs 9 plus ce qu'ils vont
vraiment être dans la lignée et
poursuivre ce qu'on a trouvé une
dernière sur les suites et suit plus le
même design même si l'écran peut être un
peu plus grand sur le s9 plus
ce qu'on voit vraiment c'est qu'ils vont
toujours plus loin
c'est ce 9 et s9 plus sont en réalité
une mise à jour des svt suite plus sûr
booster au niveau de la caméra avec de
nouvelles fonctionnalités de meilleures
performances
on va toujours plus loin on reste un
petit peu sur les acquis de ce modèle
ensuite elle suit plus bon on voit qui
aura plus de puissance plus de qualité
toujours plus et ça c'est top
alors on s'attend pas à voir un produit
révolutionnaire en 2018 chez samsung
peut-être mais pas sur ce produit là
peut-être un galaxy x mais bon pas
forcément sous ce nom là donc pour
l'instant on n'en parle pas on l'a déjà
parlé sans avoir quelques nouvelles un
petit peu plus précis de ce côté là en
attendant ses galaxy s 9 et s9 plus
s'annonce être comme des très beaux
produits
d'ailleurs si vous avez déjà insultés
suite plus je suis pas sûr que ce soit
nécessaire de changer pour passer là
dessus quand vous voulez vraiment du
super slow motion vous que la photo soit
vraiment votre dada mais sinon en termes
de coûts il ya quand même un certain
prix par contre si vous voulez faire un
coup ce que je peux vous conseiller
c'est attendre la sortie ds9 s9 plus
pourquoi pas pour aller acheter un issu
des esprits plus qui ont continué de
diminuer
vous aurez toujours un produit avec un
écran qui sera génial vous donnerai
toujours la même qualité d'écran on ne
ferait pas du super slow motion ferai
pas des photos avec
d'où l'ouverture au niveau de l'appareil
mais par contre vous aurez un produit
qui sera quand même super bien et
d'excellentes bonnes qualités voilà un
peu ce qu'on veut dire tout de suite sur
ses futurs samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est des produits qui
pourraient vous intéresser
est ce que vous pensez changé en 2018 si
oui est ce que vous pourriez partir là
dessus et sinon dit pas sur quels
produits ce que vous iriez j'attends
bien sûr tous vos commentaires j'ai hâte
de les lire elle y répondre excusez-moi
des vaches c'est un petit peu dans le
jus donc j'ai pas le temps de répondre à
tout le monde mais je vais essayer de
passer un peu plus de temps sur mon
clavier vous envoyer un petit message à
vous envoyer des petits messages et puis
à répondre tous à toutes vos questions
je vous remercie énormément bêtes là
toujours plus nombreux merci je vous
invite à laisser des jolies pousse à
vous abonner parce qu'on a toujours
parlé toujours plus toujours mieux de
high tech que ce soit de la téléphonique
soi même des objets collectés j'en ai vu
énormément c est donc il ya plein de
choses à venir je vais tenter
d'aller au mwc d'aller voir en
avant-première cs 9,29 plus je vous
promets rien mais je veux vraiment faire
mon maximum pour être présents parce que
il faut être présent sur ces événements
là parce que c'est là qu'on est au coeur
de la technologie est au coeur au plus
près des marques
merci à vous je vous embrasse abonnés ou
rester sage et je vous dis à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]